ce que j'ai vu c'est là où heures j'ai
perdu 56 enfants et il ya eu des
pompiers 56 petites victimes surtout des
bébés sur le point d'être adoptée
un an avant le séisme l'ancien banquière
et son mari avaient investi l'argent de
leur retraite pour construire un nouvel
orphelinat
quand la terre a tremblé madame louis
jacques a tout perdu mais n'a jamais
songé à ne pas reconstruire
je n'aurai pas le collège ne les
abandonnez mois va exemple les enfants
je ne fais pas il ya quelque chose au
plus profond de moi qui non je ne veux
vraiment pas méfiée parfois cet amour-là
chanter apaise les blessures le grand
sammy souhaite devenir co pilote mais il
n'est pas trop pressé de quitter la
crèche
ici on a beaucoup d'amour projet et au
balo toujours n'y a pas de liste s
plusieurs orphelins ont des traumatismes
mais évelyne s'accroche aux réussites
angéline qui avait quatre ans lors du
séisme était restée coincée sous les
décombres pendant cinq jours la petite
angevine là qui a eu la jambe coupée
mais il faut l'avoir maintenant sur
scène en train de chanter non feinte ou
réjouit le coeur il faut dire je t'aime
à tous
elles vivent
l'histoire d'un autre orphelins débute
au mémorial de l'hôtel montana
des dizaines de personnes ont perdu la
vie ici dont l'ancien député québécois
serge marcil une fondation à son nom a
été créée par sa veuve
christiane pelchat madame christiane
malades et l as oui elle a dit écoute
mans michel vous n'avez pas vous vous
inquiétez la fondation serge marcil prêt
à tout en charge
j'étais rempli de joie
michel est abandonné ses études faute
d'argent
la fondation québécoise à aider à
reconstruire leur félina dans lequel il
a grandi et financent les études
d'anciens résidents du foyer oh mon rêve
c et b les autres tant sur le plan
social et agronomie le futur agronome
voudrait mettre sur pied une bio ferme
et produire des arbres afin d'aider à
reboiser son pays ici sophie langlois
radio-canada port au prince